توسيع لما اعلنه المتحدث باسم انصار الله
الحوثيين والمعلومات المتوافره ايضا بشان
الاستهداف الجديد لسفينه امريكيه في خليج
عدن نعم هو استمرار لمسلسل هذا التفقيد
الذي بدا منذ العدوان على غزه في اكتوبر
السابع من اكتوبر الماضي ما حدث قبل قليل
هو استمرار ل تلك العمليات التي تقوم بها
جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين في المياه
البحر الاحمر لكننا اليوم امام تطور جديد
ونوعي وهو استهداف قوات انصار الله
الحوثيين لهذه السفن وهي سفن امريكيه
واسرائيليه متجهه الى اسرائيل في امق خليج
عدن وفي بحر العرب وهي مناطق بعيده نسبيا
عن مناطق سيطره انصار الله الحيثيين حيث
تقع هذه المناطق ضمنا سيطره الحكومه
اليمنيه المعترف بها دوليا نحن اذا امام
مرحله او خطوه جديده في التصعيد اتخذتها
الجماعه جاءت ايضا بالتزامن مع ما صرح به
زعيم الجماعه عصر اليوم من دخول اسلحه
نوعيه الى قلب هذه المعركه معركه البحر
الاحمر والبحر العربي ما هو لافت للانتباه
هو ان قدره او داف السفن الامريكيه
صار بالنسبه للجماعه سهلا ونحن نلحظ عدم
وجود اي مضادات جويه امريكيه كانت في
السابق تقوم باسقاط المسيرات او تقوم
باسقاط الصواريخ التي تطبقها الجماعه من
مناطق سيطرتها لكننا خلال اليومين
الماضيين شهدنا تصعيدا جديدا ونوعيا وهو
ان هذه الصواريخ والمسيرات التي تطلق صارت
تصيب اهدافها بدقه وهو ما يعني
امتلاك الجماعه لاسلحه نوويه او ادخالها
لمنظومات جديده من الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ كانت مصدر عسكري هنا في جماعه
انصار الله قد قال ان هجمات او ضربتين
امريكيتين استهدفت مدينه الحديده في
الساعه الثالثه عصرا من هذا اليوم وهما
يؤكد الروايه الرسميه الامريكيه التي قالت
انها استهدفت مواقع عسكريه للجماعه وتاتي
هذه الضربات دا ضربات شنها شنتها الولايات
المتحده مساء امس واستهدفت فيها عدد من
المواقع العسكريه هنا في الحديده بالاضافه
الى مناطق في مواقع عسكريه في البيضاء و
وتعز وايضا زمار نحن امام تصعيد مستمر
وبيان الناطق العسكري قبل قليل اشار الى
ان جماعه انصار الله ستواصل استهداف كل
السفن المتجهه الى اسرائيل بالاضافه ايضا
الى توسيع دائره الاستهداف لتشمل السفن
البريطانيه والامريكيه ردا على ما تقوله
الجماعه عدوهما على الاراضي اليمنيه منذ
الاسبوع الماضي